We have in the Bronx is pretty tough area has helped
Shape me to be a pretty tough guy on the court as well
But Kimber was a velvet sword by that I mean you cut you [you] stood feeling he didn't trash. Talk. He just played
I'm not sure
He's tall [enough] to ride the rides when he goes to Disneyland
And he's the real thing I [kid] out of heart bigger anybody I can
Throw not playing in the park. He's almost kicking up the court that was small
People always say oh, he [can't] [do] his candy back and in this candidate. I'm just like why can't why can't?
Take here. That's why it's called March Madness
In 2010-11, [you] know I knew it would be a lot of my shoulders and [know] try and leave these freshmen and sophomores
So we looked up to him. I barely thought
Season started we wasn't [rank] everybody kind of felt disrespected
Offseason wrote us off he went not sixty [eighteen] which was ridiculous
no to fuel to the fire well uconn was coming off a very mediocre season and
You know Kemba walker was a player who I won't say he underachieved his first couple [years]
But he wasn't anything [real] [special]. He definitely had a chip on his shoulder from what the reporters saying about our team
He was just extremely determined
For our team to do something
Would trickle down on all of us
we got to number four in the country and then we got into Biggie's play and
No things started to go a little downhill from there. We ended the season losing four out of five finished [nine] and the biggies
First game and the big east tournament played the ball to start off at noon on Tuesday
In Madison Square park. I mean, it's cavernous. It's empty little depressing early in the day we felt
Disrespected a little bit from [Laya] Frontcourt [Left-wing] goes to the baseline [pitch]
And that's game against, Georgetown. We just saw what point went out once again down late those guys
[Walker] fantastic good
He's gonna take the last shot. Don't went into my step back in [from] that point on. I mean you've seen it
on the
Walker
stucky
Goofball and then went in and pray
I've never seen coach cal that excited. I was hilarious jumping up light there then
[to] compose himself realize that he's changing do it him. It's a big moment. You've got history
I turn to my sisters as we walked up [closer]
We got some
And you God wince again. [I] was fighting off the naysayers who kept saying you're gonna get [titan] you got to play Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
That's too much. [I] really felt that my kids were feeding on the idea that they have no idea who we are
We're just getting better in this thing Kappa house to go
I
Gained Five Days five wins
There was a broad consensus that uconn was spent they had shot all their bullets in New York that
Yeah, maybe they could win a game or [two]. Maybe sneaking to the sweet 16, but nobody was looking at uconn saying there
They go [now]
We all felt like man if we can win the big east like that is no way
These [teams] in the other conferences can beat us
napier Little Show and go, haha
[touch-free] [season] in the big [news] hey, we're not supposed to be this good [you] [guys] okay Cincinnati. Which is a really rough game
Anyone to tie up guys we went for anybody on the baby sick
Trust in his head. I'll tell you my backing
Sweet 16
They doing a great job up until one jamaal Franklin
[mont] me jamaal Franklin number 21 a little right shoulder. [bone]. You got to go to 50 intimidating he's a
[-] New York City's invaded by too much on that one nolan. I was just in the different zone
the Monster Ticker treated
Wow, there Williams second half he came on I want to move
Walker [Fadeaway], [oh]
[the] time was going down
No, got [all] [three] [behind] one of the guys drove and found [that] guy [Jamel] home from kiss hated three I felt
The win on [my] fingers when it got past my hands
And I [looked] back. I thought for sure it was good with his trip. I just remember the ball game. I'm like
Man, it's my turn. I just like it's my turn how to feel that pain. I just knew that balls going
I'm kind of will to the right left this for [the] win
for the break we missed
24 no
game over
goes back to the final four
I try to tell those guys you know just try to embrace it because it's a once-in-A-lifetime [opportunity]
Who plays bigger than his size? He's not afraid he has a chip on his shoulder about who he is
He was the guy that you had to really guard terrific play
That's up
For so hard those guys may run after [run] that game
Just stuck with the game and pulled out a bigger possession here for the huskies
tonight gives it up liggins
The game and uconn has done it again
It's time seven Madness
He takes it inside the file. He's heading to the line it will be important [for] him to make one or two in this game
It was a pretty rough first [happen] above the game that one rattles out Smith has he wait
I mean obviously it wasn't a pretty game. You know both teams really defended well
Getting a locker room and coach start throwing stuff good news clip 20 points. We just want the kind of pace
We need to be playing and we just make a few adjustments and making tripe like quick
Please upset we went out and we play like that play man
That's a stolen lamb on his way
Bendiga Space Rock lays up and it goes
Win the Maui invitational they go 5 for 5 at the biggies 5 days and in the [six-game] [run] through
I love it
That was our 11th win, whole [season] man. It was just so surreal
You see something [like] Kemba Walker and and what uconn did
We don't forget that most time like 30 people become what they can be we did
The year if somebody was that tell me we're going to play the first night the biggest friend of man going win that championship
Yeah, I'll probably
It was like a movie. Yeah. He's going back
It was unbelievable